BUKOLA AYODELE: Many apps
have a common boilerplate.
It would be great
if there was a way
to reuse infrastructure
templates
to deploy multiple services.
Let's see how kpt
helps Bob manage this.
Bob is a lead on the
application development team,
which is currently in a crunch.
They need to launch 10 apps
for an upcoming deadline.
Most of the effort is in
the common infrastructure,
but each app requires
certain modifications
that are hard to manage
in a consistent way.
Bob's first instinct is to copy
and paste Kubernetes manifests
between projects.
But this has many downsides.
Manually having to make
changes to copy-pasted code
is time-consuming
and error-prone.
In an ideal world, Bob
would be able to define
standardized
configuration templates,
customize setting for
each specific application,
and then modify
them all as a unit.
What Bob needs is packaging.
And with deadlines looming,
he needs it pronto.
Bob asks Charlie for
help, who introduces him
to Ida, a developer
on the platforms team.
Ida explains the benefits
of config as data and shows
Bob how to use templates with
kpt to reuse customized project
boilerplate, which dramatically
accelerates Bob's work.
Kpt is an OSS tool for
Kubernetes packaging, which
uses a standard format to
bundle, publish, customize,
update, and apply
configuration manifests.
Its git plus YAML
architecture means
it just works with
existing tools, frameworks,
and platforms.
Kpt is built around a
config-as-data architecture
that bundles up Kubernetes
resource configuration.
This format is readable for
both humans and machines,
and is a source of truth
for a declarative platform.
The benefit of
reading and writing
the package content using
standardized data structures
enables kpt to apply bulk
updates, creation, and deletion
of projects, run
user-defined functions
to apply custom behaviors
to config files,
seamlessly integrate into the
Kubernetes infrastructure,
and more, which is exactly
what Bob's team needs.
Say we wanted to work with
Kubernetes example repositories
for demo's sake.
We could run the
kpt pkg get command
to fetch the entire directory.
This has a lot of files.
No fear, though.
We can use the kpt
cfg count command
to summarize the files
in a easier way to read.
You can do a lot more with
filtering and listing resource
in different ways, but
I want to take a second
to focus on using kpt to update
and validate config files.
Let's take a look at an example.
If we used the kpt cfg
list-setters command,
we can see which values were
able to use the kpt tool.
So this package
contains three setters
we can use with the kpt set
tool and the current value
of the properties.
Let's set the number
of replicas to 3.
Now one of the benefits
of a tool like kpt
is its ability to use
functions to apply changes
like this on a number
of config files at once.
So I urge you to look
into the resource link
below for a walkthrough on that.
And there you have it.
With kpt, you can easily create,
and customize, and compose
configuration packages,
while adhering
to the configuration-as-data
philosophy.
With this knowledge, Bob
is able to quickly get
his application spun up in
time to meet the deadline.
So that's it for kpt.
Make sure to check out
the description for links
to more resources
on it, and Like
and Subscribe to the channel for
more videos about Google Cloud.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]